[Music]
robotic rigs meta Rants and oh yeah a
freaking lightsaber what's next for Rick
and Morty in season seven
in the penultimate episode of Rick and
Morty season six there's a bit of a
change in the Multiverse this meanest
scientist after a typical shouting match
at the start of the episode when Morty
accepts a sword from the Knights of the
sun Rick announces that he's going to be
I'm gonna be like 22 more agreeable with
you for like maybe one episode or one
Adventure Morty is understandably wary
of this unusual Spurt of kindness from
his grandpa and he repeatedly asked what
the catch is Rick assures him that there
is no catch but in the next episode we
discover that's a lie the rig present
and a wrecking King mortar's Morse is
actually a robot created by the real
Rick who has been toiling away in one of
his secret basement Labs trying to track
down wreck Prime he assures Morty that
the robot was only present for the one
episode and that it was Morty calling
him boring that pushed him to make the
change
c137 looks about as rough as he ever has
when Morsi discovers him in the basement
as a physical and emotional toll of
hunting his Nemesis has clearly worn him
down the tragic part is the whole family
seems far better off with the robot
wreck his 22 percent increase in love
and kindness that's a profound impact on
everyone's overall happiness which makes
it all the more upsetting when we
learned that it was just one of Rick's
self-serving tricks
the Rick and Morty season 6 finale sees
the return of one of the show's most
prominent Side characters U.S president
Curtis usually stuck somewhere between
malicious villain and incompetent full
Curtis appears this time to avert Global
destruction when Morty drops his new
lightsaber at a perfectly vertical angle
it goes straight through the floor and
keeps on going heading right for the
Earth's core Curtis helps stop the
lightsaber but it soon becomes apparent
that he wanted it for himself all along
Rick and Morty has parody just about
every major sci-fi franchise known to
man and it's taken plenty of Digs at
Star Wars over the years but the finale
spends a surprising amount of time on
the spoof through Morty and the
president the writers actually discuss
the nuances of the ever passionate Star
Wars fandom it's more thoughtful than
most of the show's parodies and it
re-establishes the president as a
supremely silly character Disney ruined
it you think I wanted really lower MTV
series with bad CGI they film everything
on that one big green screen like you've
got better ideas insecure with the whole
lightsaber Fiasco has some scenes of
wreck doing experiments in his lab it's
been a while since the season six
Premiere so you'd be forgiven for not
recognizing what he's doing the device
he analyzes is one of the attack drones
present on rape Prime space station
which Rick and Morty visited in the
season 6 opener apparently Rick acquired
one of the robots to run tests on though
it's not entirely clear what information
he gleans from this we also see Rick
analyzing the dancing wreck from Red
Prime space station who's revealed in
the post-credits scene of solarx to be
in fact the man himself whether or not a
reg c-137 knows this is unclear but his
scientific analysis of the man's
bouncing butt bears fruit through all of
this Rick almost appears to be running
on autopilot he clearly hasn't shaved or
bathed in quite some time and it seems
that his revenge Quest is once again
consuming him unfortunately the answers
he finds aren't as simple as it like
them to be
using all the data collected from rig
Prime space station Hideout Rick c137 is
able to pinpoint where the villain is
unfortunately his computer starts
highlighting numerous other possible
locations the confusing thing here is
what Rick says later when he shows Morty
the Multiverse scans revealing Rick
Prime's many locations Morty asks if
he's seeing every place a villain could
be I wish Morty it's all the places he
is oh geez welcome to my darkness does
this mean that rig Prime has a bunch of
clones across a Multiverse or that he
uses some kind of time travel or perhaps
that he stays on the move and jumps
around so frequently that it's
impossible to ever pin down his true
location we don't find out for sure and
it's likely that Reg c-137 himself
doesn't actually know as he tells Morty
he spent most of his life hunting the
guy and he's hardly any closer to
Victory
by the end of Rick and Morty season 6
the hunt for Rick Prime is front and
center for Five Seasons reg c-137 hardly
even mentioned his vendeza against the
evil doppelganger but after getting so
close to the culprit in the season 6
opener Rick is back on the case in full
force and this time he's taking Morty
with him in an effort to mend fences
with his grandson after the whole robot
reveal Rick invites Morsi into his lab
and shows him what he's dug up on Rick
Prime he quickly becomes Manic and
grimly foreshadows what may happen as
they hunt the villain together hunting
him destroyed me Morty but now we're
gonna do it together you and me who's
gonna take over your life Morty despite
wreck bringing Morty in on his Vengeance
Quest at the end of season 6 the two
characters still seem some was at odds
all the Goodwill built up by Robo Rex
kindness It's a race when the twist of
his true nature is revealed and Morty
once again feels tricked and manipulated
by his grandpa at the end of season 5 he
demanded that Rick start treating him
more like an equal and for a while that
seemed to be be going well but now
things appear to be regressing however
while Rick may be reverting to his old
ways things aren't back to the way they
originally were Morty has become more of
an equal party in their Adventures over
the last two seasons and that power has
made it harder for Rick to manipulate
him Rick bringing him into the hunt for
Rick Prime will be a test for their
relationship and it should be
interesting to see how their Dynamic
plays out as they pursue the villain by
the end of Rick and Morty season 6 the
Smith family looks a good deal different
than it did at the start of the show
after a truly wild ride over the past
few years Jerry has reached a kind of
equilibrium he's still not the sharpest
tool in the shed but he's regained some
respect in the eyes of his family and is
far less pitiful than he once was of
course the biggest change in the Smith
family Dynamic is a consistent presence
of space Beth it's become a kind of cool
aunt to Morty and Summer She's also
introduced a curious element to Beth and
Jerry's relationship ethics of sleeping
with your clone aside the relationship
between the three adults appear to have
had benefits for them all with the
balance among the rest of the family at
what might be an all-time high Rick
becomes the outcast his decision to
replace himself with a robot seems
selfish and manipulative but it might
actually suggest a greater degree of
self-loathing Rick sees that his family
is happier and he doesn't feel like he
can be a part of that new Happy normal
instead of trying to get on board with
the whole happy family thing he hides
away in the basement and sends a robot's
house in his place isolating himself
from the people he's grown closest to
look man I'm sorry I've been such a dick
in the past that you think I'm doing
I'm doing here I'm
better by you are you a robot Morty it's
no secret that Rex c-137 isn't a good
person the flashbacks we get at the end
of Rick and Morty season 5 don't redeem
him but they do provide a lot of context
for why he is the way he is we see how
his life was torn apart by Rick Prime
how he dedicated his life to exacting
Revenge until Decades of failure and
subsequent violence transformed reg
c-137 into a cold husk of his former
self at the start of Rick and Morty
c-137 might be at its lowest points but
as the series moves forward he gets some
of his mojo back unfortunately Rick
takes some backward steps in the season
6 finale the way Rick looks and talks in
his underground lab evokes his darkest
moments from the early years of the show
it's clear that Rick Prime's Resurgence
has sent him on a spiral and this time
there's no telling where it will lead
him
though Vic Prime shadow looms large over
Rick and Morty season six we still don't
know much about the guy that's probably
because Rick c137 doesn't know that much
but who actually is Rick Prime and what
does he want it's implied that he was
one of the first Ricks if not the first
to develop multiversal travel his name
would seem to back that up it's also
clear that he's incredibly calculated
and psychotic even beyond the levels of
normal Ricks but why did he leave his
family in the first place does his role
as Morty's actual grandfather have
something to do with him being the
mortiest Morty and what's his overall
plan if he even has one
one character who fans may have expected
to see at the end of Rick and Morty
season 6 is evil Morty the schemer who
makes a dramatic Escape in the season 5
finale he's a reason Morty learns about
Rex tragic backstory and the reason his
portal gun is disabled at the end of
season 5 evil Morty transcends a central
finite curve and Ventures into a new
beginning wherever he goes it must be
far away indeed as there's no sign of
him anywhere in season six to be fair
that makes complete sense evil Morty's
only ambition was to get away from Rex
so why would he come back after
completing that goal it's entirely
possible that his story is now over and
that will never see him in the show
again with Rick Prime becoming the
show's main antagonist there's less room
for evil Morty anyway still it would be
fun to see him pop up again in the
future even just for a cameo Earth has
become standard Mr Poopy butthole makes
an appearance in the post-credits scene
of the Rick and Morty season 6 finale
and the time since we last saw him the
little yellow guy has gotten swole
though apparently not swollen enough for
serious squatting Mr Poopy butthole just
can't catch a break it seems since he's
often shown watching the series just
like we are he's probably in some
far-off Dimension however that doesn't
mean that he couldn't be brought back
into the main story at some point in
fact knowing Rick and Morty you can
probably count on it Rick and Morty is
going to be around for a few more years
at least reportedly the team behind the
show are already at work on season 7 and
season 8. there's also a season 9 in the
pipeline showrunner Scott murder told
Newsweek we're getting ahead and it's
awesome really exciting we're
overlapping like two or three seasons on
the records so from our perspective it's
a real Kaleidoscope the season 6 finale
gives us a pretty good idea of what the
next season May entail in the final
scene of the episode Rick flies into one
of his classic fourth wall breaking
rants declaring that the show's next
installment will be all about Rick Prime
Rick and Morty season 7 hunting my
Nemesis maybe trying to stay healthy
while doing it juggling plates not every
episode Morty could be all happening in
the background who knows it's the same
brand of non-committal fans using that
the show has become known for but it
also paints a pretty clear portrait of
what the big picture story threads of
season 7 will be we'll probably still
get mostly one-off episodes like Rick
says but here Morty will also be working
together to hunt Rec Prime with luck
we'll learn a bit more about him I won't
make a multi and the larger Multiverse
along the way
[Music]